whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold up hold
the phone wait a second no not you ain't
gonna get that past me what the heck is
that what the hold up let me get a
picture of this I'm gonna enhance it
okay Here I am with a picture man I I'm
probably just crazy but if I if I didn't
know any better those those look like
wait a second let me enhance the colors
a little bit let's get some yeah some
contrast up here maybe take the
brightness down a little bit maybe a
little bit more contrast so we can oh my
god
10,000 years ago
calamity Ganon reared its ugly ugly head
for the first time and I mean ugly I
mean just just look at this anyway it
tried to kill us try to take our world
but it wasn't successful so with the
help of the chica and the divine beasts
and guardians we beat Ganon but after
ten thousand years of plotting Ganon
just kind of came back but this time
took absolute control of all the sheikah
machines every guardian every divine
beast well except for Link's motorcycle
but I mean who knows it could have been
running around wreaking havoc before
link gets it back in the DLC anything is
possible eyes anyway once Lincoln Zelda
defeated calamity Ganon at the end of
breath of the wild it can be assumed
that since we see the strange sheikah
pillars more on those later in the video
by the way turn blue instead of the
Ganon possessed red palette and the
divine Beast
stop acting so crazy after you release
them from the other Ganon cz's controls
Aza's mm-hmm it can be assumed that
Ganon no longer has control of any
sheikah machines following the defeat of
calamity Ganon but now that we know
Ganondorf is coming back for breath of
the wild sequel I got to thinking man he
already took control of like an entire
machine army complete with giant killer
animal BOTS and laser shooting walking
octopus thingies and we still beat him
what could he
Sibley do worse and then I saw this
what's up guys mask and a band appear
and today I have a crazy theory for you
that just might be crazy enough to work
are you intrigued yet yeah so am i I'm
so intrigued I'd like to get right into
the video actually and real quick before
the content hits I just wanted to remind
you that I am a real person sitting
behind a real computer and it would be
seriously cool if you were to hit like
if you enjoy this content and subscribe
for much more zelda content to come also
that way youtube will recommend this
video to others just like you anyhoo zzz
that's all i had to say about that if
you did end up liking my video or even
subscribing them thank you
you're the bomb i look forward to seeing
you next time anyway thanks for watching
enjoy the video and without further ado
here we go okay so by now you've
definitely gathered that I am absolutely
implying Ganondorf has built his own
divine beast and it is hyrule castle or
at least under it or in it or both you
know probably both actually let's look
at this three ways one why would he do
this to how would he do this and three
when did he do this to me the why is
simple as I already touched on earlier
Ganon has been beaten I'm not just
talking about the time and time again
that Lincoln Zelda defeat the forces of
darkness together but we literally have
beaten calamity Ganon just recently
complete with his ultimate arsenal of
the very weapons we used against him ten
thousand years ago in addition to this
he's currently a corpse or a mummy like
the sheikah mummies we encounter in the
game one has to ask the question what
exactly can he even do in this state I
know he could act like the other mummy
boss in the DLC and just kind of fight
you one-on-one maybe sprinkle a little
malice in there you know spice things up
but I don't know that seems a tad bit
underwhelming especially given Ganon's
track record of his final form usually
being Ganon which again we have already
defeated I think it's very plausible
that Ganondorf would take things to the
next logical level since the sheikah
machines are obviously a huge ally to
have and make a big impact on the
outcome of the battle why not make
a better one a bigger one a stronger one
because hey if you're Ganon form ain't
working out for you why not make a
divine Ganon okay so how would Ganondorf
go about building his own divine beast
well if we were to look at two things
real quick one of which is Zelda's
Journal found in the Hyrule Castle area
I believe this one I'm referring to is
her research journal not her diary you
know not the one that's filled with her
linked fan fictions you can read that
those pillars I mentioned earlier you
know the ones that surround Hyrule
Castle actually used to be buried deep
in the ground so deep actually that
Zelda's entire excavation team couldn't
find them just knew of their existence
due to sheikah lore so why is that
important you ask hold your horses I'm
getting there the other thing to
remember is actually quite obvious you
do know that all of the sheikah stuff
and I mean all of it came from under the
ground right as in there is a bunch of
machinery down there who knows how much
more may still be buried the reason why
I brought up Zelda's team's failure to
find the giant pillars is to prove that
there is a glaring possibility that the
hylians may have not may probably have
not uncovered all the sheikah technology
that's been buried deep under the ground
over the past 10,000 years so most
likely the parts and pieces and gears
screws shafts Springs cores
you know this stuff that we farm up here
all the time that's all under the ground
Ganon would have more than he needed to
build whatever he wanted and it's
already been seen that the MAL is
pouring out of ganondorf's body is
pretty capable stuff I mean it does this
this this and even this all the other
Ganon's we see in-game are made of
malice too with this sometimes sentient
substance just pouring out his body like
the stuff and in my hot pockets I think
it's also plausible the malice could
excavate beneath the earth find pieces
and build a divine beast after the
things built it could even give it life
like I was saying this malice stuff is
pretty freakin legit yeah at least you
know for uh Ganondorf
obviously
okay so we have why and how down pretty
well I'd say but when would gain and
accomplish this at what point in time
did he assemble this giant divine beast
well this is obviously the one part of
this theory that can't be answered for
sure because we don't even know how much
time has passed between breath of the
wild and the sequel yet for instance but
I see only three possible answers to
this
first up he could have assembled the
machine in the ten thousand year gap
while he was busy studying the sheikah
technology and formulating his master
plans already the only reason why this
wouldn't make too much sense is that he
didn't use it in the events of breath of
the wild secondly he could have
assembled it in the hundred year gap
between Lynx defeat and his reawakening
knowing link would return and knowing he
would need a big bad weapon but again it
could be argued that he already had
enough on his hands while doing battle
with Zelda for that century long gap and
he also didn't bring it out in the
battle with link the third theory is
that he crafted the divine beast just
now after the events of breath of the
wild and before the sequel this one
makes the most sense as it feels like a
natural progression following his defeat
at the end of breath of the wild all
right I feel like now is a pretty good
time to say not to quote anyone here but
this is just a theory now I happen to
think it's a pretty good one given
ganondorf's previous obsessions with
hyrule castle and his tendency to you
know every once in a while have it float
above a lake of lava I feel like this
would be a really cool addition to the
breadth of the wild world that would
really shake things up but what do you
think let me know in the comments below
also be sure to like this video if you
enjoyed and subscribe for much more
content in the future as always keep the
hype real and I'll see you next time
peace
[Music]